[Música]
muy buenos días comenzamos este
informativo con una noticia en
desarrollo que viene desde parís la
capital francesa donde se presentó un
ataque cerca a la antigua sede del
semanario satírico charlie hebdo y se
reportan hasta el momento dos heridos
uno de ellos se encuentra en estado de
gravedad pero no en peligro de muerte
dos sospechosos ya fueron detenidos en
el lugar estuvo el primer ministro jan
castex quien se refirió a los hechos
escuchemos parte de lo que fueron sus
declaraciones
tratarlo acudir
tengo aquí
he querido mostrar mi solidaridad hacia
los familiares las víctimas e igualmente
hacia los colegas de trabajo de los dos
periodistas
son años
de ese abismo de ellos los servicios de
seguridad y de socorro a quienes rindo
homenaje intervinieron rápidamente para
ejercer su trabajo en estas
circunstancias sencillo bien
y esto sucede en un lugar simbólico y en
un momento en el que se desarrolla el
proceso contra los implicados en el
ataque contra charlie hebdo de 2015
es el momento para el gobierno de la
república de recordar su defensa de la
libertad de prensa y su voluntad firme
de luchar contra el terrorismo y de
afirmar le a la nación nuestra máxima
movilización era firme a la nacional por
plena movilización
también estuvo en ese lugar el
procurador de la ciudad de parís seremi
hate se quien confirmó el arresto de
estas dos personas relacionadas con los
ataques además de la apertura de una
investigación antiterrorista escuchemos
sus palabras
la comisión antiterrorista ha abierto
una investigación antiterrorista por
tres razones primero la ubicación de
esto precisamente delante del inmueble
donde antes estaba la redacción de
charly eto'o segundo por el momento en
el que se realizó el hecho es decir
cuando se está desarrollando el proceso
contra los autores de los atentados de
enero de 2015 y por último teniendo en
cuenta la materialización de los hechos
es decir la voluntad manifiesta del
autor de atentar contra la vida de dos
personas que estaban en ese momento
simplemente en una pausa para fumar red
y también sobre este hecho se refirió el
presidente del consejo europeo charles
michel que condenó el ataque lo calificó
como un ataque cobarde con arma blanca
junto a esta antigua sede es parisina
del seminario satírico
charlie hebdo ma entonces ahí están ya
después el rechazo por parte de la
comunidad europea de la boca del
presidente del consejo europeo charles
michel vamos ahora entonces a la capital
francesa donde se encuentra una de
nuestras a periodistas
erika olavarría erika en la capital y en
parís también se desarrolla entonces el
juicio contra los implicados que
estuvieron relacionados entonces con el
ataque a charlie hebdo en el año 2015
donde en esa oportunidad lamentablemente
si fallecieron personas y varias también
resultaron heridas él le preguntó si en
el marco de este juicio y luego de las
amenazas también que tuvo en una de las
trabajadores de charlie hebdo si no
estoy mal fue la jefa de recursos
humanos por las publicaciones que hacen
en referencia al profeta mahoma que han
también rechazado los musulmanes en
múltiples protestas y también contra las
amenazas contra este diario le preguntó
si tendría algo que ver este ataque con
este juicio que se está desarrollado
en parís además como lo está manejando
la prensa en ese sentido y también las
autoridades
claro siempre ocurre un hecho como este
de raúl hay que ser muy prudente pero
obviamente las alarmas saltaron cuando
se supo que había un ataque cerca de la
antigua sede de charlie hebdo hay que
decir que la sede actual de este
periódico satírico no se conoce está en
el amplio secreto por lo tanto el lugar
más simbólico donde sobre todo hay un
mural con los rostros de los que
fallecieron ese día de enero en el año
2015 es esa sede que ha sido atacada hoy
o que en realidad no fue atacada porque
fue muy cerca de allí que ocurrieron los
ataques pero las personas que son
víctimas de este ataque los dos heridos
pertenecen a una sociedad de producción
que está instalada en ese mismo edificio
que habían bajado a tomar un cigarro
entonces obviamente se hace la relación
sobre todo como tú decías hace un mes
comenzó ese juicio donde hay 14 acusados
11 presente 3 que están en la ausencia y
que están acusados justamente de haber
ayudado materialmente o intelectualmente
a los tres atentados que hubo en enero
del 2015 el atentado contra charlie
hebdo pero también en la
contra el supermercado calle de la
puerta de avance ni contra una policía
en la comuna de mockus y desde que
comenzó ese juicio ese mismo día la
revista publicó nuevamente las
caricaturas de mahoma esto fue visto
como una provocación hubo inmediatamente
amenazas de parte de al qaeda y de
incluso reacciones de países de mayoría
musulmana después hubo las amenazas como
decías tú contra la directora de
recursos humanos directamente que
obligaron a que ella dejara su domicilio
viviera temporalmente en otro sitio y
esta mañana también se dijo que se había
encontrado un paquete sospechoso en el
mismo domicilio que podría también tener
relación con el ataque o y por lo tanto
no se puede no se puede obviar toda esta
actualidad lo dijo el mismo fiscal
antiterrorista de parís que ha sido no
es cierto convocado para llevar esta
investigación junto a la policía
judicial
raúl así es erika y por ahí también
entonces fueron las declaraciones del
fiscal de parís y el primer ministro por
eso también yo sacaba a colación en este
caso
que dimos en el 2015 en charlie hebdo y
además también que el director de ese
medio luego de que se publicara
nuevamente estás a estas alturas contra
el profeta mahoma y en el marco de este
juicio él afirmó que defendía la
libertad de prensa y que iba a continuar
publicando a lo que ellos les parecía
conveniente publicar en su revista erika
y con toda esta situación entonces de
seguridad que vemos en la capital
francesa le pregunto cómo puede afectar
esto a la gente en parís
bueno obviamente que cualquier ataque de
este tipo es algo que despierta un poco
la angustia entre la ciudadanía que como
recordaba el ministro del interior de
armani al comienzo de este juicio la
amenaza sigue siendo muy alta
extremadamente alta decía él en parís y
en francia y los franceses son
consciente de ellos además estamos en
una época complicada debido ya a la
crisis sanitaria no es cierto en que
estamos viviendo una segunda ola en que
hay la posibilidad de un nuevo
confinamiento entonces son tiempos
complicados y obviamente en la
actualidad del juicio es abierto lo que
significa revivir ese momento duro no
sólo para la gente que obviamente
resultaron lamentablemente heridas o que
perdieron a familiares pero en general
para la ciudad de parís es un momento
traumático recordemos que incluso la
alcaldesa de parís fue a testimoniar a
este juicio un testimonio por cierto
polémico pero ese es un momento
traumático para la ciudad para quienes
vivimos aquí y por lo tanto que hay un
ataque implica revivir todos esos malos
recuerdos y además erika el año
siguiente luego de ese ataque 2015
2016 los ataques a el teatro bataclán
también en una zona de restaurantes muy
muy concurrida en la capital francesa
entonces obviamente eso pues remueve la
figura de lo que han vivido los
franceses en los últimos años por cuenta
del terrorismo pero pues esperemos a ver
entonces qué es lo que finalmente dicen
las autoridades erika yo la dejo pero le
pidió que se quede con nosotros porque
quiero ir hasta más cerca de este punto
del lugar de los hechos donde se
encuentra nuestra periodista natalia
ruiz
natalia la saludo nuevamente y le
pregunto qué es lo último que se sabe
hasta el momento en torno a este hecho
que ocurrió en la capital francesa
bueno pues no hay más informaciones ya
ustedes escucharon al primer ministro
son caseros también escucharon a fuerza
a la director del ministerio digamos que
ese ministerio público que toda esta
parte que se dedica al anti anti
terrorismo y por ahora lo que puedo
decirles es que aquí ya levantaron todo
el cordón policial ya los carros estamos
viendo a circular sobre la avenida de
ficharles sobre está sobre esta calle ya
la gente de alguna manera está pudiendo
volver a tener su vida un poco más
tranquila porque ahorita hablábamos con
un padre de familia que tenía una cita
antes ya no puedo pasar hasta allá
porque justamente donde nosotros vivimos
es justamente allí donde se produjeron
los hechos hoy así que les decía estaba
esperando pero ya hace tiempo que unos
cinco o diez minutos la policía ya
digamos de todos los diferentes pero
digamos cordones de seguridad que se
habían puesto aquí en las zonas y que de
alguna manera ya está comenzando todo va
a regresar a la normalidad y seguramente
pues en lo que
seguida del día sabríamos habla un poco
quizás más de informaciones al respecto
seguramente ya más bien desde el imperio
del inferior si así estatal y usted dice
entonces que las autoridades ya se están
retirando el lugar no sé si entonces
debido a esta retirada de las
autoridades del lugar ya han bajado o
retirado como la amenaza que había en la
zona por este por este hecho donde
resultaron heridas dos personas
sí así es
en realidad
donde graban la reacción al desaliento
así que ya están levantados todos estos
cordones de seguridad si ya los carros
de policía se han ido ya la situación
está bajo control así que la seguridad
es una manera pues ha regresado en todo
caso a esta zona de tarifas y que por
eso ya pues como ven a está retomando la
vida normal de este viernes confianza y
así es natalia y también por último
quisiera saber entonces si tenemos ya
informaciones sobre a lo mejor una
atracción de algún grupo o de alguna
persona sobre este caso todavía no se
sabe nada al respecto de quién podría
estar detrás de estos ataques y fue un
caso aislado
por ahora también es decir se va a
presentar una investigación seguramente
como en un lugar que hasta ahora no se
ha hablado de la identidad de uno de los
dos sospechosos que aparecer seguía una
paquistaní de 18 años pero por ahora las
autoridades no han dado más detalles
constantes ellos siempre son muy
cuidadosos de vamos a adelantarse a
aventurarse así que por ahora estas son
las informaciones para que existieran
las autoridades como dijimos por ahora
muy reservadas en cuanto a lo que viene
ya en cuanto a adelantar la
investigación que en realidad apenas
acaba de comenzar así de natalia gracias
por la información por supuesto vamos a
estar nosotros aquí en la redacción de
france 24 en español muy pendiente
entonces a lo que ocurre en la capital
francesa con respecto a estos ataques
donde al parecer
está poco a poco volviendo a la
normalidad según lo reportada nuestra
reportaba nuestra periodista en el lugar
en natalia ruiz natalia gracias
nuevamente y quiero ir entonces ya para
ir finalizando y haciendo las
conclusiones de lo que ocurre en la
capital francesa con nuestra periodista
eric olavarría ericam le preguntó
entonces si se han conocido más
reacciones políticas fuera de las
esferas del gobierno de mayor makro
aunque ya las hemos comentado y la hemos
visto en este informativo especial aquí
en france 24
bueno hay que saber que el presidente
manuel macro el elíseo él no ha hablado
pero el elíseo comunicó que el
presidente estaba siguiendo muy de cerca
estos hechos básicamente la líder del
partido ultraderechista reunión nacional
marine le pen dijo que esto demostraba
el fracaso del gobierno en la lucha
antiterrorista recordemos que ella ya
está en plena campaña preelectoral de
cara a los comicios presidenciales del
2022 por lo tanto este el tema de la
seguridad es un tema justamente que está
en el tapete que es uno de los que está
se están disputando tanto el gobierno
como su contrincante de extrema derecha
por lo tanto ella está haciendo ya una
utilización política el resto de la
gente sobre todo como decíamos
solidaridad con los servicios de
seguridad y con los familiares de las
víctimas y de estos dos periodistas no
es cierto que ya vivieron muchos de
ellos el trauma de los atentados de hace
cinco años y que hoy han sido tocados de
ellos en carne propia uno a su nombre el
otro es una mujer para que lo sepan y
respecto a los autores se conocen
algunos antecedentes pero el autor
a 18 años y antecedentes policiales
aunque no terroristas y la otra persona
que está detenido todavía no se puede
confirmar si participó como autor en el
hecho pero es una persona de 33 años sin
antecedentes policiales raúl así es
erika entonces y ahora el sospechoso
principal de este ataque el paquistaní
de 18 años de edad por supuesto también
tenemos que estar muy pendientes a lo
último que salga a erika gracias por
esta información y también recordemos
que entonces fue el 13 de noviembre de
2015 cuando 130 personas fueron
asesinadas en la serie de atentados en
la capital que comenzó cerca del estadio
de la capital francesa luego del teatro
bataclán quien en el 2016 y no en ese
mismo año en noviembre de 2015 cuando se
presentaron esta serie de atentados y
acabaron con la vida entonces de 130
personas es todo un poco como para hacer
un contexto de lo que han sido los
ataques terroristas que ha vivido la
capital francesa hasta que den
información france24 continua con
nosotros
[Música]